[Music]
Happy Friday, hello to Héctor Mejía
and this is your briefing The cases
of coronavirus continue to rise in
Nevada Yesterday the governor says so here he
announced that the state needs to take
urgent action to stop this
contagion otherwise the hospitals will not be
able to cope  status will remain in phase
2 however bars that do not sell
food will have to close again
starting tonight additionally
restaurants will only be able to allow 6
people per month those in pools
or gyms will need to wear masks
unless they are active inside the
water or exercising
the state's special legislative session will
continue today in carson
series lawmakers have not yet voted on the
plan to fix this
state deficit the debt is $1.2
billion due to closures following the
virus outbreak
the board of directors of the  cis has already
unanimously approved the
school reopening plan, this consists
of students  students attend school two days a
week and three days
from home online after several
hours of debate the board voted in favor
of the plan but said it will only be
temporary and there could be changes
in the future and now we pass over
time  another sunny day with temperatures
reaching 109 degrees we will have more
heat for the weekend
exceeding 110 degrees so stay
hydrated and avoid being in the sun
for several hours have a great
weekend i am hector mejía this was
your brief  kirchner news in
spanish
[Music]